et pour en parler nous sommes nous avec
yves buisson épidémiologistes président
du groupe coville 19 à l'académie
nationale de médecine
marie-christine duniaud médecin
généraliste au consulat français de rio
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france 225
mille morts et en variants qui affole
les scientifiques de la planète partout
au brésil pour commencer parce que l'eau
avait ce juge le variant brésilien très
préoccupant quelle est la situation sur
place marie christine d'union alors
qu'est-ce qu'il faut d'abord dire que le
brésil c'est un public de 101 millions
d'habitants d'accord on a 9 million deux
cent mille cas de cogiz positif bien sûr
ça fait une moyenne ces derniers jours
sur sept jours la moyenne est calculée
sur cette jv opare avec 14 jours au
précédent on a une moyenne de cinquante
mille cas par jour c'est à dire une
augmentation de 8% de plus à chaque fois
pour les décès c'est exactement pareil
on est déjà à 2 126 mille et quelques
desserts c200 t6400 quelque chose comme
ça ça fait une moyenne de 1066 décès par
jour
et c'est aussi une augmentation de 10%
par rapport au dernier à la dernière
quinzaine alors quand aux variants
brésilien si on l'appelle de variants
amazonien puisqu'il vient dé d'amazon il
a été décrétée d'abord en amazonie il
faut reconnaître que il ya très peu de
tests qui sont faits c'est dommage mais
le brésil n'a pas les moyens et une
pénurie absolument de pinzi au point de
vue laboratoire qu'au point de vue
recherche etc
donc on a moins dont on fait moins de 1
100 de séquençage de génomes
mais on sait que en réalité il se
diffuse dans tout le pays dans ses pas
seulement en amazonie à manaus par
exemple au mois de janvier il y avait 4
ans
3000 cas de de provident positif bien
sûr et de ses 33 mille cas il y avait
90% de d'identification du var y avait
identifié quatre dans 80% des cas
faut dire que manaus à deux millions
deux cent mille habitants
mais que de mars de l'année dernière à
décembre manaus n'avait eu que 76 mille
cas donc ça ça part en vrille 1 et il a
été identifié dans plusieurs état
d'autres états du brésil dont temps en
particulier rio sao paulo etc
voilà un désastre massif des
informations qui semblent peu rassurante
ce variant un brésilien qui décidément
est très préoccupant et qui donne
d'ailleurs quelques sueurs froides aux
chercheurs les vaccins aurait
manifestement aucun effet dessus selon
certains vous confirmez 800 étaient sans
corde et des notions qui doivent être
précisées on n'a pas encore de résultat
totalement définitif
toutefois il apparaît que effectivement
une des mutations porté par ce variant
amazonien puisque si la plaie comme vous
le souhaitez et une mutation qui porte
le nom eu 4 184 cas qui on retrouve
également dans le variant sud africain
est une mutation qui est corrélée à une
moins bonne sensibilité à l'action des
anticorps développés après la maladie
naturelle coville 19 ou après la
vaccination
donc effectivement il ya une crainte
dans ce domaine que ce variant s'il se
répand limitent l'efficacité des
campagnes de vaccination mais ça veut
dire quoi concrètement qu on peut quand
même rassuré nous
marie-christine d'union oui 800 je ne
sais pas lequel des deux est le plus
compétent pour répondre à cette question
mais ça veut dire que à l'instar du
vaccin contre la grippe on peut quand
même le faire évoluer plus ou moins
facilement
pour ce qui concerne les vaccins qui
repose sur la technologie de la rn
messages et les producteurs de ces
vaccins ont clairement indiqué que le
l'adaptation de leurs vaccins ou
nouvelle souche donc aux variants était
une chose qui était très aisé à réaliser
puisque ils envisagent que il faudrait
six semaines environ pour mettre au
point un vaccin adapté aux nouveaux
variants donc effectivement se
trouverait dans le schéma de que nous
connaissons les avis de la grippe avec
la nécessité d'adapter autant que faire
se peut là les vaccins à utiliser la
spécificité des nouveaux variants
marie-christine d'union c'est à la fois
rassurant parce qu'on peut adapter les
vaccins d'après
yves buisson met enfin à la fois pas
rassurant parce qu'elle quand même déjà
une pénurie de ce premier vaccin qu'on a
peine à fabriquer en temps et en heure
faut-il s'en inquiéter pour les mois
voire j'ose même pas et prononcez le
mans mais voir dès les années suivantes
oui je pense que oui parce que d'abord
ici au brésil on a seulement commencé
maintenant on a commencé au mois de
janvier à vacciner on a pas de vaccin
pour l'instant il n'y a pas eu
d'autorisation de la part de la haute
d'en face qui cauris poulies saisi la
haute autorité de santé pour auto les
autoriser les vaccins à arn messager on
utilise ici le vaccin chinois corona
vague qui est fabriqué par le
laboratoire sinovac et le vaccin qui
vient d'oxford astrazeneca qui est à des
adn recombinant si je ne me trompe pas
c'est comme ça que ça s'appelle donc
pour l'instant on a seulement réussi à
vacciner moins de 1% de la population
alors est taillée
oui oui oui vous en prie non c'est assez
inquiétant parce que d'après tout ce qui
est prévu de d'arrivée de nouveaux
vaccins et de fabrication de nouveau il
ya deux bien deux instituts si un
président qui sont responsables de
fabriquer les vaccins partir bien sûr dé
son chauffage pas comment ça s'appelle
des souches qui viennent des autres
laboratoires
c'est l'institut est un institut à sao
paulo qui s'appelle 80 ans qui est
responsable de fabriquer le corona vars
à dire le vaccin chinois et un autre
institut et signaux qui s'appelle fille
au crous qui responsable de fabriquer le
vaccin de l'astra zeneca ce conte ce
qu'on prévoit d'ici le mois d'avril
je dis bien d'ici le mois d'avril ce
serait qu'on devrait réussir à fabriquer
230 millions de doses
c'est à dire qu'on arrivera à vacciner
au maximum avec deux doses où la moitié
de la population
ou alors qu'on arrive à vacciner que
toute la population avec une seule dose
donc c'est assez inquiétant il n'y a pas
tellement de
perspectives par rapport au vaccin russe
au spoutnik 5v ya la haute autorité de
santé l'itie détermine que les tests de
la phase iii se fasse également ici au
brésil sur la population bien sûr or la
haute autorité de santé dit qu' il ya eu
il ya une demande bien sûr d'un
laboratoire qui se dit prêt à fabriquer
novak salonique ici au brésil pour faire
pour commencer cette étape de test de la
phase 3 or la haute autorité de santé a
dit que les russes n'avaient faire la
russie n'avait pas encore fourni tous
les documents
donc c'est pas un vaccin qui s'il
arrivera il va pas arriver tout de suite
donc pour l'instant mené un petit peu
dans cette dans ce status quo par
rapport aux pique-niques et puis surtout
dans une pénurie de vaccins on vaccine
ici d'abord les soignants les gens et
personnes âgées de plus de 85 ans on a
on les indigènes c'est à dire les
populations autochtones mais on n'a pas
beaucoup n'a pas de chiffres disons
qu'ils nous permettent à on n'a pas les
moyens qui nous perd qui puisse nous
permettre de nous permettre de vacciner
un grand nombre de gens alors que ce
serait absolument nécessaire parce que
l'épidémie elle part en vrille alors on
est depuis le mois de novembre ça
n'arrête pas d'augmenter et lui sont
marqués christine d'union nous parler à
de spoutnik vais effectivement un vaccin
efficace à plus de 91 % d'après the
lands est le brésil était un des
premiers à y croire depuis lé début
c'est le vaccin qui pourrait changer la
donne y compris on ne rend pas est un
vaccin qui présente effectivement deux
des qualités qu'il reste à confirmer
c'est évident le premier les premiers
résultats semblent très encourageant
avec ce résultat de 91 % d'efficacité
c'est très très encourageant le système
utilisant des adénovirus deux années de
virus différents
pour la première injection pour le
rappel qui est un système très astucieux
qui permet d'éviter que la réponse
immunitaire contre le premier vecteur
empêche le deuxième celui de la deuxième
injection d'être efficace c'est un c'est
avec ça qu'ils se présentent bien qu'ils
pressentent sûrement beaucoup d'intérêt
il serait nécessaire effectivement en
europe comme au brésil que les
formalités administratives ne soit pas
trop longue
compte tenu de l'urgence épidémiologique
quand on a affaire à une épidémie d'une
telle ampleur qui parsèment le pays d'un
si grand nombre de victimes chaque jour
je crois que il faut aller vite je dis
pas qu'il faut le bousculer les étapes
indispensables pour valider le vaccin
mais il faut aller très vite il faut pas
se perdre dans des méandres
administratifs car la population doit
être le plus rapidement possible
vacciner d'autre part il ya une sorte de
course contre la montre avec les
variants on peut espérer vacciner à un
grand nombre de la population qui n'a
pas encore été en contact avec le virus
pour que l elle oppose une certaine
résistance par l'immunité collective ou
aux différents virus qui rend bien même
sont-ils variant encore une fois ces
variants montre une certaine résistance
une vitre on a aux anticorps développés
après vaccination ou après la maladie
mais ce n'est pas une résistance totale
donc c'est une moins bonne sensibilité à
ces anticorps
ce qui fait que si on vaccine
massivement une population population du
brésil en l'occurrence il y aura un
effet de freinage très important sur 7
sur cette épidémie
mais il faut s'en donner les moyens au
brésil comme on est rock on voit que on
est contraint on est confrontée à ces
difficultés d'approvisionnement rapide
en un nombre très important de doses de
vaccins il évite pas sûr que ça
fonctionne comme ça la vitesse n'est pas
toujours le fort de l'europe et
notamment en france où il va falloir
patienter pour cette production de
spoutnik
vais je vous propose d'écouter emmanuel
macron qui nous dit attendre les
homologations évidemment nous ne pouvons
pas le distribuer en france tant que le
producteur russe n'a pas soumis une
autorisation de mise sur le marché à nos
autorités
et c'est normal c'est une question de
responsabilité sanitaires à la minute où
il la déposera dans les meilleurs délais
les autorités européennes et avec quelle
chacune deux autorités nationales
évidemment regarderont scientifiquement
de manière indépendante
ce vaccin est en fonction de ses
résultats et des preuves
le mot lowbrow ou pas c'est pas une
décision politique c'est ça que il faut
comprendre l aeem donc l' agence
européenne du médicament est ce qu'elle
peut mettre sur la touche
le spoutnik 5 parce qu'on a souvent il
faut bien un trône est entendu un petit
peu souffrons sur fond de russie reçoit
phobie railler ce vaccin au départ on
pourrait faire de l'idéologie politique
là dessus marie-christine d'union où
finalement la fin justifie les moyens on
a passé le cap
et voilà il faut aller maintenant à
l'essentiel et à l'urgence
vous êtes confiant je pense qu'il faut
aller à l'essentiel et à l'urgence parce
que vraiment la situation la pandémie au
niveau mondial je crois que c'est
quelque chose qui est qui qui est
terrible c'est tout c'est absolument une
destruction de absolument tout le
sociétal de économique je parle même pas
de la destruction des familles qui
perdent leurs peurs êtres chers
donc je pense qu'il faut il faut aller
vite maintenant sont pas faux pas mais
qui dès au logis au milieu parce que ça
sert absolument à rien il s'agit de vies
humaines
il s'agit de il s'agit de la survie de
gens qui vont ensuite pouvoir retourner
à l'école travailler normalement et
c'était donc voilà c'est vous qui lui
sont cette vidéo logis l'agencé
européenne du médicament est une agence
véritablement indépendante
oui j'en suis persuadé elle est
nécessaire cette agence il faut bien
voir qu'il y à 2
deux éléments à prendre en compte pour
la validation d'un nouveau vaccin
tout d'abord il ya les éléments
scientifiques et le document qui
viennent d'être publiées qui me rapporte
l'étude de phase iii de ceux de ce
vaccin sont très très encourageant il
nécessite bien entendu un examen par des
esters scientifiques indépendants
qu'israël qui seront beaucoup plus
poussée mais je crois que de ce côté là
il n'y a pas trop de difficultés ce
qu'il faut également concevoir c'est la
production l'étape industrielle de
production de ces vaccins
or il faut que soient homologués les
laboratoires qui vont produire ce vaccin
pour le produire dans le bon respect des
pratiques qui garantissent la qualité de
toutes les doses de vaccin on peut pas
se permettre d'avoir une dose sur 100000
qu'ils soient pas de bonne qualité et
qui apporterait des effets secondaires
indésirables
donc il ya ces deux aspects la recherche
scientifique d'un côté qui est
semble-t-il est de très bonne qualité ce
qui n'est pas étonnant de la part de nos
collègues russes qui sont des
scientifiques très éprouvée de très
grande valeur mais il ya également
l'étape industriels c'est un autre
métier que de fabriquer le vaccin une
fois qu'on a la recette est fabriqué des
doses devait des quantités de doses
aussi énorme en si peu de temps
cela ne s'improvise pas donc il faudra
que les laboratoires qui seront chargés
de produire ce vaccin soit homologué
aussi est assez garantissent la qualité
des millions de doses qui seront à
fournir merci beaucoup à tous les deux
lui son est marié à christine dinho en
direct donc de rio d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france